a Hollywood figure already heavy with  honors is about to put on more weight  four times president of the Academy six  times producer of these annual attempts  to be guide you into your neighborhood  theater farmer Thalberg winner whose  personal productions have garnered 21  Oscars over the years and a friend of  movie audiences and picture makers  throughout the world our Board of  Governors tonight salutes with a special  Oscar the lyrical mr. Arthur freed  thank you Bob I could never write a  lyric that would properly express my  gratitude  I've been reverting back to my job keep  the show moving will you okay thank you  thank you out there  you're nudging Betty Davis you know